okay so the topic of this video today is
you know how to build a cladogram so why
don't we go ahead and get started well
first of all the Plata gram is a
branching diagram that is used to show
how related organisms may be to one
another and characteristics that they
might share in common well to begin let
me look at this table right here I'm
going to put an X underneath the name of
every organism that has a backbone you
can see the human fossil the mouse the
lizard the salamander and fish well
these are all vertebrates
they all have backbones well now of
these five species which of these have
lungs well everything excuse me
everything but the fish if I look at
these five fossils well which one of
these five have claws or nails yeah well
that would be the lizard the mouse and
the human and you'll see why I'm doing
this in a moment
which of these five species which ones
have fur well it would be the mouse and
the human mouse named mice and humans
are mammals and then which of these have
an opposable thumb well that would be
the human okay you know you're gonna
start to see why this was important in a
moment to get started with my cladogram
I'm really just going to draw a straight
line from bottom and angling upward and
I'm gonna use this straight line as my
main branch in my cladogram and one
thing I like to look for is what is
something that they all have in common
you know all five of these have a
backbone but then I need to look for
what is a play that you've all probably
played the game one of these things is
not like the other well of the five
animals which is not like the other four
I can see from my checks or my exes in
my table that the fish are not like the
others because the fish don't have lungs
everything above everything besides the
fish has lung so I'm gonna make us my
first branch is gonna separate the fish
and everything above that branch is
going to be labeled with lungs
well that's because fish don't have
lungs you know they breathe with the
assistance of gills
well now what now when I look at my my
ex is in my table now that the fish has
been separated is there any of the four
animals left the salamander the lizard
the mouse and the human how is one of
these different from the other and you
can see that of the four left
salamanders don't have claws or nails so
I'm gonna branch off next with my
salamander and the reason I chose the
salamander is because the lizard the
mouse and the human have claws or nails
salamanders are on a separate branch you
might know that they lack claws they
don't have claws or nails okay so now I
have the lizard the mouse in the human
between the lizard the mouse and the
human how is one different from the
other two in my ex at the table with my
exes I can see that the lizard doesn't
have fur but the mouse and the human do
that tells me that the lizard is going
to be my next branch and above that are
gonna be animals with fur you should
know that lizards don't have fur okay so
now let's come down to the mouse and the
human how can i distinguish between the
mouse and the human well I can see that
mice do not have opposable thumbs but
humans do so that would branch off the
mice and on the right side this branch
opposable thumbs would lead to humans
and the branch of the mice of the mouse
well you know you might know that they
have no opposable thumbs
so in this cladogram that I've now drawn
I can kind of start to analyze and and
see relationships and similarities you
know one thing I also want to point out
cladograms can be kind of viewed as a
timeline starting at the bottom is
longer ago and near the top is kind of
present-day
so I can see and this matches to the
rock layers on the right hand side of
the screen I can see that the fish are
at the bottom of the rock layers well
that's why they were the first one to
branch away as well see how the data
matches because the fish are the oldest
of the organisms they were the first
ones to branch
according to the rock layers I can see
that the salamanders are a little
younger of a species than the fish and
that's why they branched off next when I
continue up the rock layers
I come to the lizards notice how the
lizards are are in the middle of the
five and notice how in my cladogram
they're in the middle of the five to
branch away and then finally I'm getting
nearer the top we have the mouse which
branched off and then at the very top
the most recent of features the most
recent of these creatures at the top in
the human so when I look at the plate of
em that I drew and I compare it to the
fossil evidence
hopefully they match and I don't have
any discrepancies okay so now I can kind
of do a little bit of analysis according
to my cladogram which of these organisms
have lungs you can see the
characteristic of lungs is flashing just
to kind of draw your attention to it
well how do I read this well from that
label up from the label of lungs from
that point up everything from that point
up possesses lungs that would be the
salamander the lizard the mouse and the
human everything below that point which
is only the fish in this example does
not have long so the correct answer
would be the human the mouse the lizard
and a salamander if I were to give you
this question what does a lizard any
human have in common according to this
cladogram let me just highlight in red
the branch of leading to lizards and the
branch leading to humans
well everything before they branch they
have in common that would be the
backbone there would be lungs there
would be claws or nails and that's it
notice how the lizard's now split to the
left and the humans split to the right
but everything before the split
everything before they separate they
possess in common why could this
cladogram or any clade agree why would
it be considered a 10th
of hypothesis you know this is a harder
one you know pause the video and think
about it
well the reason why a cladogram would be
considered a tentative hypothesis is
because we're always learning more
information you know we're building
cladograms with the amount of
information that we have currently new
discoveries new observations could shed
more light and could change our view of
their evolutionary history and so keep
in mind if we're if we're using fossils
to build a cladogram you know the fossil
record is very incomplete there's gaps
in the fossil records you don't often
get full fossil fossilized skeletons you
get fragments of organisms and so you
know we might be misinterpreting the
fossil evidence so keep in mind any time
you see a cladogram it's our best
hypothesis it's the best guess at the
time that it was created new information
could cause it to be recreated let's do
another example of it later let's kind
of do a silly example first modes of
transportation here a bicycle a car or
motorcycle an airplane walking on foot
and a unicycle well I mean I like before
let me use the X's which of these modes
of transportation has a motor well that
would be the car the motorcycle in the
airplane which of these has at least one
single wheel well that would be
everything besides walking on foot which
of these modes of transportation has
wings well that would be the airplane
which of these modes of transportation
is the writer enclosed well that would
be the car in the airplane which mode of
transfer of transportation requires
energy well that would be all of them
even walking on foot requires energy
from your own body and which of these
modes of transportation has multiple
wheels well it would be the bicycle of
the car the motorcycle and the airplane
okay so how can we get started I'm gonna
draw my nice straight line like I did in
the previous example and I'm gonna look
for one thing that they all have in
common right here they all require the
use of energies that's gonna be my
beginning and characteristic well now
like we did before let's play the game
one of these things is not like the
other which one is not like the other
well that's pretty straightforward I
hope walking on foot that's gonna be my
first branch it's not like the other
modes of transportation because all the
other modes of transportation have
wheels and of course walking on foot
does not
so now that I'm foot has been eliminated
of the five that are left the bicycle
the car the motorcycle the airplane in
the unicycle which of those five is not
like the other four there it is
multiple wheels so I know that a
unicycle would be my next branch because
everything remaining has multiple wheels
but a unicycle has only a single wheel
so of the four modes of transportation
left the bicycle the car the motorcycle
on the airplane of the four that are
left how is one different from the other
three well there it is I can see that
the bicycle is gonna be my next branch
because it's not like the three that are
left it's not like the car the
motorcycle in the airplane they have a
motor a bicycle of course is on a branch
that does not have a motor well between
the car motorcycle and airplane how what
would come next the car motor suck on
airplane how is one different from the
other two that are left well that would
be the writer is enclosed I know that a
motorcycle has to be my next branch
because a car in an airplane have the
writer enclosed and of course a
motorcycle is and the riders not
enclosed it's open to the wind and then
between the car and the airplane between
the car of the airplane you know how is
one different from the other well
there's my characteristic of wings I
know that the motorcycle excuse me
between the car in the airplane I know
that the car is gonna be next because
though the wings leads the airplane and
the car is on a branch layabout no wings
well let's analyze this really quick
if I were to ask you to list the traits
of a car well let me highlight the path
that the car is on and when I do all you
have to do is is read what's on that red
line I can see energy yeah has a wheel
in fact has multiple wheels has a motor
and the rider is enclosed you could
probably even say it has in no wings but
it's not having a characteristic really
a characteristic so that's why I always
in my answers here I label the five that
the car actually does possess which
modes of transportation would possess a
motor you can see the motive is flashing
to draw your attention to it but like we
saw in the fossil example a moment ago
from this point up from that
characteristic up everything has a motor
so you can see I hope there are three
answers the motorcycle the car and the
airplane they all possess a motor and
everything below that the bicycle the
unicycle on the foot does not okay so
here's the last example in this
presentation of building a cladogram
let's look at these rock layers here
pretend that these are the fossilized
remains of some animal species that
lived a long time ago so don't view them
as screws and nails pretend they are the
fossilized remains species ABCDE NF I'm
going to build a cladogram out of these
six species right here so I'm gonna draw
my straight line now remember a Plata
gram is a time line the bottom look of
the time line represents longer ago
species B is buried the deepest well
that tells me it's the oldest now before
we start branching them off what's one
thing that they all have in Canada well
I can see that they all have a pointy
end on them
now that I've identified one character
with a all possess I'm gonna start
branching and separating these so now I
can start to play the game of one of
these things is not like the other
I know fossil B is gonna be my first
branch because it's the oldest so how is
fossil be different than all the others
above it well I hope you see a pretty
obvious distinction
everything above fossil B has a straight
body
but fossil B has a curved body okay so
now I'm gonna work my way up the rock
layers and I come to species F I know
that species F is gonna be my next
branch cuz it's the next fossil species
that I encounter so how is fossil F
different from all the other ones above
it probably the most obvious thing that
I noticed is that everything above
fossil F has a head fossil F does not so
as I work my way up I now come to
species a so I know species a is gonna
be my next branch well if I play how is
any different than c e and D I hope
probably the most obvious thing that
sticks out to me is that everything
above fossil a has spiral threads going
around its body
however species a does not have those
spiral threads as I continue to work my
way up
I come to species D and so species D is
gonna be my next branch well how are
this piece is above species D how are
they different
well the most I think the most
recognizable thing that I can see is
that C and E have some kind of pattern
on their head but species D does not
have a pattern on its head and as I come
up to species C next well what is
difference between species C and species
E I noticed that species C has a plus
shaped pattern on its head while species
C has a minus minus shaped pattern on
its head and so now I can do a quick
analysis you know when I analyze this
this you know very fictional cladogram
here what a species a and species C have
in common
let me highlight in red their individual
paths and so we can see where they split
they split right there
where that blue arrow is indicating that
means everything before the split they
have in common that would be a point a
straight body and a head that's those
are three things that I know that
species a and C having kin
by reading this cladogram which species
has spiral threats we've done this now
in a couple examples from this point up
everything has spiral threads that would
be species D C and E everything below
that point BFA do not have spiral
threads and as I said earlier why would
this cladogram be viewed as a hypothesis
a tentative hypotheses now granted this
is just a silly example he's on two real
animals and and fossils here but if this
were a real plated lamb involving real
animals or plants or organisms again
cladograms are very much viewed as
tentative hypothesis because of missing
information there's gaps within the
fossil record there could be some data
that were misinterpreting so a cladogram
it would be considered fluid it could be
adjusted and amended as more information
is discovered and so there you have
hopefully three examples of building
cladograms and i hope you found this
video helpful thanks for watching